- Davante!
- Aaron?
- Shhh. Listen.
- "Today on Rogan, we're gonna talk
about spiders: Should you eat 'em?"
- Please come back. You complet...ions me.
- Is everything OK?
- Go back to bed. We can't be losing sleep, too.
- Does he take you to big games?
- He takes up less cap space.
- [Voiceover:] After a bad breakup, can this
perennial bachelor find a real catch?
- The trick is just to find a generational talent and then bury all the
annoying parts of your personality.
- Kirk, drive me around.
- I'll try.
- [Voiceover:] The heart only gives…
- Blast them sides, Rodgers.
You look great!
- [Voiceover:] What it can receive.
- Wrong route, you stupid a—
- [Voiceover:] With Aaron Rodgers…
- What's your favorite part about the Pro Bowl?
- [Voiceover:] And, uh, Allen Lazard and some guys?
- Never been.
- I'm Sammy Watkins.
- I dunno.
- [Voiceover:] This fall…
- Look, things change. I used to be a punter,
and now I'm a media darling. You need to be open.
- They need to be open!
- [Voiceover:] Some missed connections…
- [Together:] Why do you even want us back?
- So I can throw to ya any time I want.
- [Voiceover:] Will make you wish you ran for it.
- Goddamn it, guys! Keep your eyes open!
-[Voiceover:] Forgetting Davante Adams.
-I'm just a quarterback standing in front of a receiver asking him to take a paycut for my sake.
-And most of all, I hate the way these new guys don't catch the ball. Not even a little bit, not even at all.
-I wish I knew how to quit you...and the Packers.
-Nah, just the Packers. I mean, Jerry's been begging me to join the Cowboys.